I watched your YouTube videos before Oh
you do yeah they're very inspiring for
sure lots of interesting stories oh
definitely it's like a voice for for us
that you know sometimes we need to be
heard like
that how long have you been in this kind
of
situation uh well it's been a while now
since I mean honestly I've been like
running a Muk since I was like probably
14 that's when I started but being in in
skid Road Road it's been like already
like couple a year or so but yeah I just
hit skid Road like 2 months ago and
those two like these two months have
been hectic like I never thought I was
going to be right there as skit R like
how I've been like these past two months
that's how I met him and like certain
other people you know but it's been
crazy how how old are you now 27 how'd
you get introduced to this lifestyle uh
my mom which my mom game bang she was uh
she always was selling drugs like that
she was a single mom so that's how she
did to raise us you know um just was
around in my whole life my dad too you
know he that's what he did to do move
stuff around but I started using at the
age of 11 because when of my mom's
friends gave it to me to try and
then uh yeah and then at 14 I had an
accident where I got ran over by a bike
I was on top of a hill and I was going
down a mountain and uh I remember I had
no brakes no helmet and there was a car
coming 90 miles per hour and here I come
you know I I just see my life flash
right by through my like through my eyes
and I get hit bam I red head first and
then walked onto it and so I cracked my
skull and like it made me start eternity
bleeding that put me instantly into like
a coma I was in coma for 2 months and a
half and then that's when I got addicted
to opiates you know but I was on life
support for 2 months and like they were
I wasn't supposed to make it nothing you
know like but I feel like my childhood
was stolen ever since that time that
happened because that's where all my
drug addiction really started because
that's where I was on Opia they had me
on delen oxycoton from the age of 14 to
17 by the time they took me off I was
already hooked on it you know I started
looking for it in the streets and like
getting you know that turned into like
smoking heroin from heroin too
unfortunately fentol you know yeah so
I've been smoking fentol for like
already like 4 years and how have you
been making money
[__] um for a while I was I was
escorting you know I kind of stopped
that for a bit because I had a situation
that went wrong and it kind of made me
kind of hold back a bit cuz I was living
way too fast what happened
um well I knew some Russian couple that
they they had like took me over to their
place they were swinger couples that's
how I met them and they told me they had
uh they had some a customer a client
that wanted to see me and it was going
to be a party with a bunch of girls if I
wanted to go I was going to make a lot
of money so I was living with that
couple for like four five days cuz I was
homeless when I met them and then
finally they they got my trust they
gained my trust in all that and uh when
I went to the party like I ended up
showing up there was nowhere no one
there mind you before I got there they
drugged me they drugged me with some
drug called GHP you know I was like it
was like if I was conscious but I my
body I couldn't do nothing with my body
I couldn't like hold myself up nothing
but I was consciously still like you
know aware of what was going around so I
just remember then we get to the it was
like we get to the place it was in
Hollywood we go up we're going up like
towards like the Hollywood Hills and um
some some guys come out first it was two
of them and like I already feel it I
already see it like the whole it was all
sketchy you know and I'm crying I'm like
trying to like tell them like no I'm
like what are you doing you know the two
the two guys took me out and then when I
get in there it was already like six or
seven of them and like I thought I was
going to get human traffic like that's
why I thought I was like [__] I'm going
to die right here you know but I don't
know why they didn't kill me that day
but I don't know they did what they did
and then um then they just one of them
was like I told him I was like man make
sure when you're done you kill me cuz I
don't want to live after this and he's
like don't worry about it I'm not going
to have to kill you you're going to have
to kill yourself after this cuz you're
not going to deal with the pain I really
you know that [__] [__] with me and
after that like I was I went bad like
they took a to of me like I was going to
commit suicide and everything but they
raped you yeah seven of them like and I
guess what that Russian couple sold me
to them you know I didn't even know
about I didn't even know that so finally
when I they just told me get up and
leave you know obviously they knew I
wasn't going to go to the cops I was
like afraid to even tell anybody cuz who
was going to believe me I was in escort
like nobody's going to believe in escort
for [__] like that you know so um I just
just went up about my day I went to go
see if the Russian couple were there
it's like they vanished nowhere to be
found I never saw them ever since then
you know W and like yeah that sh was
crazy um apparently they were doing
fraud so they you know they the
apartment was didn't even their real
name like I didn't even bother trying to
look for them or like I just I was just
like [__] it it happen you know I blame
myself for it because um the way I was
living you know that situations I was
put I was risking to put myself in
situations like that and to me that was
like a big eye opener to me you know
because it broke me but I I told myself
I I I refuse to be a victim of that you
know I'm a Survivor of that [__] you
know so it's not going to take a to out
of me how it did so I you know I had to
get myself up have you worked the
streets as well yeah yeah I had to but I
stopped that it's been a couple years
and and yeah it's been hard ever since
but I've dealt with guy that doesn't
mean I still don't deal with [__]
[__] on a day-to-day B basis you
know they see a pretty woman uh
[__] with no family type of stuff you
know Amon like or fentanyl they they
they they take advantage of that type of
[__]
but that [__] is Al it's made me like
you know it's built me though to the
person I I I'm trying to be and is is
making me like you know if anything I'm
grateful for all the like downfalls and
all the stuff I've gone through
cuz yeah it's been a hell ride you know
I just got out of a a relationship uh
couple weeks ago like the dude would
like beat my ass every single day for no
apparent reason like every day like if I
Dr if I made one certain noise he didn't
like I'm so and I apologize shut the
[__] up [__] you're [__] useless all
right I'm sorry I told you shut the [__]
up and then he would just grab me beat
my ass throw me outside the apartment
with all my clothes he would keep all my
clothes he knew I had nowhere to go I
was it was my first time I got to Skid
road because of him you know he took me
there cuz he has an apartment right
there um in skid road so that's how I
ended up in SK R so every time he would
kick me out I would have to walk around
and would knowwhere to go late at night
you know not knowing [__] I was at first
yeah I was scared but thank God like a
lot of people there like I guess the way
I carry myself they they if anything
they they're cool with me you know they
look out we all look out for each other
one way or the other but yeah it's kind
of hard being a pretty girl walking
around in skid R you know like it's it's
crazy sometimes you attract the wrong
attention sometimes I attract you know
but it's it's always like different
attenion that I I attract do you have do
you have kids yeah I have a daughter
where is she my mom went in Mexico she's
s years old her name is
Serenity yeah oh yeah I mean I miss my
daughter I love my daughter to death you
know I try to be there as much as I
could like financially wise but I can't
be there for her emotionally because um
you know I was broken you know I had to
try to heal myself first in order to be
able to be there for my kid so what was
the roughest part of your childhood uh
well my mom's an alcoholic you know
she's she's just like my grandfather my
her she had a her father was an
alcoholic always beat her you know she
always told me stories of how he would
beat her and stuff so kind that kind of
let like my mom my mom didn't my mom
didn't really beat me but she was like
she never like really gave that
affection that love you know like it was
always like she was more like my friend
you know like Mom can you buy me weed
she'll buy me weed can you buy me beer
if my friends wanted a ditch she we
would go to my house and we would do
ditching parties there like my mom was
like the cool mom you know like but
never was like the supporting mom that
like I really needed you know my mom
just did her thing you know and I always
just was very like on my own I always
kept get myself to myself so I'm the
middle child out of three my older
brother and then I have a little sister
and I'm the middle
child yeah but
um the roughest part of my childhood see
I don't think I had it that rough
because my mom did her best by doing
what she had to do but I guess just
being around that lifestyle of her gang
banging and then like the drugs and all
that I didn't get to have a childhood
like that you know I I had to kind of
grow up in a fast type of stuff you know
it was a way to like to protect myself
and and like you know I just I was
always very quiet I was always making
sure I I looked at everything everybody
was doing like everybody thought I was
not I didn't know nothing I knew
everything that was going on you know
and uh yeah my
mom my mom uh to this day she she she
asked me for forgiveness she feels like
it's her fault that I ended up on drugs
but I tell her it's not you know because
I'm I'm an adult now you know I could I
have the choice whether I let the drugs
affect me or I could I could stop you
know I've tried to stop multiple times I
even went to Mexico for a whole year
with my mom and my daughter went cold
turkey I was sober for like a whole year
got healthy chubby and U do you have
tissue by the way yeah sorry about
that um and I was doing good but then
you know the minute I I got out here to
Cali like you know back to [__] like
I never I haven't had a stable place for
like who [__] I don't even know what
home is like no more like you know to me
home is like where my family's at you
know I have that out here my mom's in
Mexico and my dad well my real dad I
don't really talk to him you know he's
German he's a white guy my mom used to
sling to him I guess I was a one night
stand baby that's what they
say
but yeah I just you know emotionally
what do you go through living this LIF
St emotionally yeah a lot of [__] up
[__] like you know I guess a lot of
times like I'm the type of person like
I'm very vulnerable very kind so I
always like trust people without like I
don't now I've learned that people don't
always have the same intentions or the
same mindset or the same heart that I do
and I've always been put in situations
where like I've gotten hurt especially
by men like you know and like uh the
father and my child that's the one who
[__] me up the most like you know
one time when my daughter was like three
months I was breastfeeding her he was
always very he was like very always
cheating on me we were both young though
he was um I was 19 and he was uh 17 I
when I lost my virginity is when I lost
my virginity at 19 years old I got
pregnant that same time that like you
know I had sex with him and then next
thing you know I I cut him off because I
was embarrassed of and humilated myself
three months after I find out I'm 3
months and a half pregnant with my
daughter you know and we're both still
young like do doing like youngster stuff
so I tried to I got my sister together I
was I was working but my baby daddy was
just you know so one time when I had my
daughter um I was breastfeeding her he
had took some Zanax he was definitely
high off something you know he comes he
wanted to sleep with me I didn't want to
sleep with him I'm like hey you know I'm
still healing from the C-section like I
don't want to be with you you've been
with girls I'm I'm tired I want to take
care you know you came to see the baby
not me that turned into an argument like
[__] you that's why I don't so he took
out a gun and he like clogged it hit it
and it didn't go off he's like damn
[__] even with death you [__] have
luck and he went by pistol with me and
all this from here to here was all split
I just remember hearing like a a loud
beep and I wanted like I was going in
and out I hear my daughter cry see blood
on her I thought he shot me I was like
what the [__] I don't even know what's
going on I'm screaming his name like he
like cuz he R he started running
I didn't mean to say his name but next
to you know uh I find I I black out I
black out but I remember just like so I
don't know if God gave me the strength
or whatever it gave me the strength I
woke up I woke up to my daughter crying
that's what got me to get up I put a
[__] towel when I saw on the lip all
my thing was split up you know I had to
drive myself to the hospital when I get
to the freaking hospital I told them I
made a lie said I got on a fight with
some lady so they obviously had to call
the cops to make a report you know my
baby daddy was already there at the
hospital with me officer gets there he
sees my baby daddy he told my baby daddy
hey can you step out of the room for a
minute cuz he saw that I want I didn't
want to really talk you know he's like
step out of the room and then uh so my
baby daddy stepped out of the room and
next you know he's like why are you
covering up for this [__] and I
was like what are you talking about he's
like yeah why are you covering up for
him he's like you know he did this to
you I was like no he didn't man how long
you going to let him be putting his
hands on you and especially with your
daughter like that you want your
daughter to be raised like to be
thinking that's okay you know you know
you know he's like you know what if you
don't care about yourself you know
that's child endangerment right and I
was
like sorry about that I was like yeah I
know that's I was like what do you mean
child endangerment why I I haven't done
nothing to my daughter my daughter's
good well if you know if you don't want
to press charges you don't want to be
honest and tell me that it was him I'm
going to have to do it myself I'm the
the you know the da is going to pick up
their own case and you know know and
we're going to arrest him right now cuzz
we know it was him we your neighbors
told them told us that we heard the
arguing and all that and that it's not
the first time he beat
you so yeah they picked up the case next
thing you know two weeks later they come
they arrest him behind them was DCFS you
know they took my daughter from
me and [__] my daughter was only 3
months and I was like what the [__] I
was a good mother I you know I had an
attachment with my kid my kid was doing
good you know I did everything for her
but when they took my daughter from me
that's what [__] broke me the most
like you know you're taking my kid away
and like you know it's not my fault I
get it I was defending him and they kind
of have a point you know
but yeah and ever since then like my
mom's had my kid and like I tried
building that bomb with my kid again
it's like there's like a like something
there like that that blocks it you know
I don't know if it's because I'm
insecure about it that I was not the
best mom and I feel guilty about it
but yeah definitely I feel like I [__]
up there
yeah my baby daddy he was doing seven
years for that they gave him seven years
he only did five he came out recently
like four months ago he had came out and
he's right back in 10 years now now they
gave him 10
years what he go back for uh [__] uh
he was uh he got caught take like
basically pushing drugs to another state
pounds you know and he I knew he wasn't
going to last you know I didn't even
bother trying to to tell him to get
involved with my daughter because I
didn't want to give my daughter that
like half fasting you know I've had to
like lie every time for her like on
Christmas and [__] like i' be telling
like get buying gifts and saying that
it's from her dad or i' be having my
homies like do me the favor and call and
pretending like it's him to say happy
birthday to her cuz she wonders like
where's her dad you know I don't know
what to tell her he's at
work cuz she tells me like why do all
the little girls have dads and not me
like you're not normal Mommy because you
don't have a husband and you're with me
so I'm like
[__] that [__] [__] with me a
lot what's your biggest regret no you
know I'm not being there like how I
should because I love my daughter to
death and like not really like not
loving myself enough to give myself
like the the the the love that I need to
be able to like be healthy for her and
for like myself you know cuz I've dealt
with [__] that I shouldn't have dealt
with
people are malicious and evil out there
you know like I don't know sometimes I
be thinking D being a good person comes
with a curse as well but I think that's
what a lot of people want they want to
break me you know you know cuz I feel
like when you have a light inside of you
like you're going to trct two different
type of individuals either broken
individuals that are in need of your
light or people that are going to try to
dim it n out of 10 is going to be those
that are going to try to dim it cuz they
can't you know
but I've dealt with some [__] crazy
ass [__] people like I don't I feel like
everybody hates me for no like friends I
don't have friends because every girl
that I know they're like straight up you
know they is just it's just weird so I'm
a Loner I'm always alone I like to be
alone that's when I get myself you know
that's how I learned how to like cope
with myself and get
myself yeah do you have any friends no I
have no friends I don't have friends at
all like I really don't I don't have
someone that I could con say hey you
know can you help me
out so when I go through [__] I go
through it like I can't call my family
cuz my mom's really depends on me for
money I don't really have any immediate
family like that either but
um that's how I learned to survive you
know right now I'm hustling I do I
honestly I go and I steal from stores
like I'll come up on like hygiene like
big bottles and I'll go and I'll sell it
to like these ladies at my caret Park
that you know that's or I what I you
know I try my best to just keep myself
going know it's a common way for huh
it's a common way for people in skido to
make money that's yeah it's really but
it's really nothing cuz you know they
pay $2 like I'm risking my freedom type
of stuff you know like at the end of the
day sometimes it's either I choose to
eat or I choose to get high obviously
I'm going to choose to get high what's
your biggest fear now my biggest
fear just
uh [__] just staying stuck in skit Road
and like not coming out of it and not
and having my daughter like resent me
and and and follow the same steps that
I'm in you
know I feel like just
not not getting out of it you know and
staying stuck on drugs forever like and
just not finding myself how or finding
my purpose or doing what I got to do to
get my you know cuz SK Road I feel like
I hit the rock like that's like the pit
hole you know I never like what I feel
like I hit rock bottom being there like
at SK R you know like but it's like I'm
stuck there like you know once you're
there it's kind of hard to get out
there's a lot of people that don't get
out I know and that's what scares me
but the other day I was just walking
down the street on a right there on by S
Julian Street and there was somebody
getting picked up a dead body they
wrapped them more you know they're
picking them up and like because of how
cold it was you know that [__] [__] with
me I was like
damn that's why sometimes I I can't
complain because yeah I'm struggling I'm
homeless I don't have nowhere to stay
I'm like here there everywhere but
I think about the people that really
don't be you know that guy died out of
like coldness cuz of how cold it is I'm
the type person if I have a sweater and
I see someone that's cold I know I could
go get a sweater you know these some
people the they're not mentally capable
of going to get what they need for
themselves so I'll take off my sweater
and I'll give it to them even if it's my
last I don't care cuz I know what it is
to struggle I know what it is to not
have it you know people see a pretty
girl like me they think oh she comes
she's good she comes from like you know
no if I look like what I've been through
I look like [__] I would look like [__]
you know but I've had to try to like
disguise my my my pain and not and not
come off as that broken individual
because I don't want to show myself as a
weak person cuz then they they they'll
pray on me like that you know people
pray on weak on weak women you know and
I don't want that to happen anymore to
me so I have to put up the image of I'm
good and that you
know what would you say is your greatest
strength my my greatest strength my my
struggles you know my struggles are my
greatest strength because that's when I
found myself the most you know when I
was the most broken I found what I was
capable of you know CU they either like
they say either you let it make you or
break you you know like I said I'm not I
refuse to be a victim of that [__] and
my biggest strength would be I can't say
my daughter cuz if it was I would be
doing my [__] right now you know but
I yeah you feel like life is
unfair it's not unfair we make it unfair
you know certain things we make
unfair
but um no I don't feel like it's unfair
sometimes we go through certain things
um for for I feel like everything we go
through is all for a purpose or for a
reason you know everything and sometimes
like what we think it might be a curse
it sometimes could ends up being a
blessing and disguise you know that's I
try to look at it the way that's what
keeps me from you know trying to see the
the light and the dark you know cuz I'm
not and damn I'm going to stay in that
victim mentality I'm not going to get
nowhere you hear me yeah do you do you
have any good memories of of your
childhood yeah I
do with my
brother my sister yeah I miss my brother
I haven't talked to my brother for like
a couple years but cuz the last time he
saw I saw him he threw me out like a dog
he humiliated me and like that hurt me a
lot so I forgave him you know some
people he didn't even have to ask for
forgiveness for me to forgive him cuz
that's my brother and I love him you
know but yeah my mom used to try to take
us to Disneyland like every other
weekend when she when she would have
good money
but I had some good memories yeah my mom
my mom did her best You know despite her
pain despite her trauma she she loved me
at her best capacity you know that's
something I had to understand now as an
adult like I can't hold no grudge on her
the way she cuz she holds a grudge on my
grandmother I can't hold that Grudge on
her cuz she loved me the best she she
could just how I love my daughter the
best I could you know just you know
despite my trauma despite what I've gone
through and
stuff no one's perfect so I don't judge
my mom either I don't judge
anybody that's
nice what do you think people don't
understand about this lifestyle that you
you're
living they don't understand that a lot
of times you
know
like us we we be we be we be this
lifestyle because for like me
that I do it because it it numbs me you
know and that might sound like a stupid
ass excuse but it's the only way that
they get away and it sometimes they look
at us as like we want to be there but
sometimes it's hard to get out of it you
know like sometimes you try to do things
to try to get out of there and there's
always something that will come and
knock you down it's not as easy as it is
and nobody could do it alone nobody
could do it alone everybody needs
somebody with with their emotionally
support cuz that's what I need that's
what always makes me um relapse that my
depression I get real depressed right
after you know they don't understand
that with it it comes it's like it's all
we ever really known a lot of these
people that live this lifestyle it's all
we ever really known you know and how
are we going to do different we don't
know any different you know it's what
comes from childhood from you know you
saw this in your childhood yeah so it's
all I've ever known and and I'm even I'm
afraid to get out of my comfort zone we
we look for Comfort drug drug addicts we
look for comfort and stuff that's why we
do drugs so we're we're afraid to get
out of our comfort zone cuz we're afraid
to see what it might you know so that's
what people understand
that that's what it
is we were afraid to get out of a
comfort zone and then we're comfortable
cuz it's all we all really had when we
when I had no one the drugs are the one
the only thing that made me feel at
least better like you know
unfortunately but
Clover what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life the most important lesson is
um is [__] [__] honestly the most
important lesson
is not loving my not being not being
there for myself how I should have and
um damn I have a lot of lessons that I
have learned but the most humble the
most one is is is being humble you know
because just just how how you can be up
there one day life will come and take
everything away from you if you don't if
you take it for granted cuz I took my
mother for granted I took my child for
granted I took all that for granted I
had a home before I took it for granted
so that's why now that's the biggest
lesson I could have tooken you know not
not appreciating the things that I had
when I had it
and yeah that's what I don't know that's
what I think is my biggest lesson
not taking advantage of the things that
I should have when I had had
them you
know as a drug addict we we
procrastinate a lot and we we don't I've
missed a lot of opportunities but that
that's okay because um that's the past
you know and I've learned to not ever
stay stuck in the past anymore I've
learned to just forgive everybody
certain people they do their things not
you know you got to understand that
people when they work out of anger it's
because they're broken individuals as
well so you gota you know I can't just I
try not to become like them I just try
to understand them and see where they're
coming from cuz I know what pain is like
you
know I just I've always loved people and
I never felt what what being loved is
like that's how I feel with my partners
and I think it comes from like my mother
you know cuz I've always looked for that
love but you feel like you were loved
when you were a kid no no I like I I was
like the my mom I swear like my mom like
put all her atttention on my brother
because my brother was the oldest and
she was the afraid about him gang
banging so she with all her attention
was on him and she say that that's her
king that's her everything you
know I was more like the the baloney in
the S of the sandwich you know in the
middle she really like I did whatever I
wanted to you know and
like to this day it's kind of like that
but I kind of stopped seeking for that
love you know and learned that I have to
give it to myself first in order before
I try to look for it and anybody else
cuz how am I supposed to learn how to
how am I supposed to to look like allow
someone to love me healthy if I don't
know how to love myself first you get me
so that's also one of my biggest lessons
is learning to make myself happy and
make my love myself first before I could
do any of that heal my wounds so I don't
break other individuals you know cuz
when you're broken broken people break
people you know and that's why a lot of
my people my dudes they they they they
broken me because they're broken people
I try to build them and they break me
doesn't make sense
hurt people hurt people huh hurt people
hurt people
yeah I I just pray for them you know I
hope that they find the the the peace
and the the what they need to be able to
heal and so that they don't be they stop
being the people that they are cuz some
of these [__] they they do evil
[__] for no reason you know
like I don't know how can you say you
love somebody but then you're going to
hurt them and do everything just to like
hurt them they make me feel like they're
jealous of me and or like like they hate
me like that's not that's not love
that's hate you
know but I pray for them they they'll
find their healing you know everybody
ends up you know hopefully life doesn't
have to come and like shake them up
because life will probably come and
shake them up just how it shook me up
cuz I had my rot Awakening and it was
when I got raped by those seven men
that's when [__] I think that was like
the hardest thing I had to go through
despite like everything everything else
that's one of my biggest traumas and I
had to heal that it still [__] with me
some sometimes but I don't let it get to
me like before how long did you do sex
work uh for like two years I used to do
um private bashet parties you know I
never worked at a strip
club but I would I was making money I
was I was only like 23 I was like you
know my Prime I feel like those were my
prime years I was looking good making a
lot of money don't get me wrong every I
walked down SK Road I got [__]
pulling up like hey how much you
know I did it like last week cuz I was
so desperate for money you know I I had
no choice I had no money like nothing in
my
pocket [__] 150 he offered me for
like a hand job so I took the offer you
know
but yeah every day I get asked to you
know but when I used to when I used to
work I had I had my my personal private
like you know I had clients that they
were my regulars and stuff you know and
I I tried to be like Health
like you know take care of myself in
that way you know I would go check
myself in the clinic and all that but
then after a while it just gets out of
like you start you start you know caring
you stop caring for yourself
eventually and then also I I wasn't able
to have sex for pleasure anymore it was
all because my my mind was programmed
out now any man I see I have to get his
money you know and it's going to be for
okay give give me your money and just do
your thing and that's it I was I
couldn't have sex for pleasure after a
while like so once I stopped and you
know yeah once once a sex worker it's
almost like always a sex worker yeah you
be yeah it's like you program to that
money and sex are are hard to try to get
rid of yeah it's almost like that's
another addiction you know that was one
of my rushes like that I love the like
the rush I would get from it like seeing
the money like I mean who doesn't love
sex and who doesn't love money like to
be realistic you know but you know I I
would probably go back to escorting but
that's not what I wanted you know but if
I have to survive I'm going to have to
do what I got to do you know like I say
no shame in my game cuz ain't nobody
feeding me providing for me I do that
for myself so therefore like I got to do
what I got to do to survive and eat you
know you
know people are going to say they're
they're going to judge me but those
people that judging me they're not
they're not putting no warm food in my
stomach you know I don't I don't ask
nobody for [__] I'm not I don't feel
entitled to nothing you know you know
but I know that I got to survive and
sometimes like I got to do what I got to
do you know that's hustle escorts we
hustle that's what it is you know we get
talked down on a lot but
hey we make the we make the world go
around sometimes you know it's true
though but yeah
all right Clover thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I wish you
lots of luck hope you give back to your
daughter okay I appreciate you thank you
thank
you